are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
gentlemen we're live all right so folks
i've interviewed a lot of interesting
people today this man is fully qualified
in that category william roger reads but
we'll call him roger highest paid
drug pilot in a history
uh worked with uh
pablo escobar ochoa
got arrested did over 30 years in jail
in
26 different prisons seven different
countries four different continents
and he escaped five times
there is some kind of a connection with
uh a man named william uh some call him
bill some calling william but it's i
think his name is william bill clinton
arkansas yeah we'll talk about him we'll
talk about the city
uh that they almost named the movie
after the city right men uh they almost
named it uh
it was written as men it was written as
mena and then they changed it and uh uh
stories left and right reportedly was
responsible for five billion dollars
worth of cocaine entering the united
states
um
some interesting opinions about pablo
some interesting opinions about ochoa at
the time pablo being the seventh richest
man in the world but who was counting
his money anyways but uh aside from that
i mean listen 50 60 million dollars of
earnings in the 80s
uh there's a lot of stories i'm so
curious to get into with that being said
roger reeves thank you so much for being
a guest on the podcast it's a pleasure
thank you and by the way your voice is
insane i can listen to that voice all
day it's a radio voice it's a pleasure
you know the way you speak it's
incredible i'm from iran so my accent is
a different kind of an accent yours is
from georgia i prefer yours oh
thank you it's like classy but also
ready to party at any moment absolutely
yes yes
so
you know you
some of us wake up one day and we say i
want to go into real estate some wake up
they say
i want to be a cop i want to be a
bodybuilder i want to be a financial
advisor i want to be a nurse i want to
be a doctor
who wakes up and says you know what
i want to be the highest paid drug pilot
in history how does that happen
it doesn't happen like that at all so
it's not like when you were a kid you
said when i grew up i wanted
i wanted to be a farmer i wanted to you
know have a big plantation of tobacco
and yep and uh then i uh i started
flying and i wanted to be a missionary
aviation fellowship pilot i wanted to
fly the missionaries in and out of the
gym seriously yes seriously that's why i
learned to fly
wow and then your heart was always in
the right place
absolutely i mean i'm not a
preacher but i could fly those sick
people in now the jungle and the
missionaries and bring them their mail
and there was a a
nate saint started it and with a little
plane and he'd put a rope down and put
the bucket and right at the missionary's
feet and they'd put their
note in it he'd put him some penicillin
in it and then mail and bring it back
out and they started that until they
could cut out strips in the jungle and i
thought wow what kind of wonderful
flying that would be
and then later on in the first story my
book i tell when i was shot down over
the amazon and i was 11 days
and who rescued me except missionary
aviation fellowship
full circle
did you did you like uh
somehow meet a pastor that was smoking
too much weed and snorting too much coke
and you got connected is that kind of
how this happened not at all i just read
the book and i thought i'd like to do
that yeah jungle pilot's the name of the
book the wonderful book and they made
the movie the point of the spear
point of the spear uh-huh interesting
that he was killed in in ecuador when he
landed was on a sandbar with
the indian people wow i'm assuming
you've been to ecuador as well yes yes
beautiful place
so so you're going you're doing what
you're doing and then you become a pilot
and then somehow somewhere you get
affiliated with these folks
it happens so gently let me just tell
you how how clearly these things can
come about
i was a i had a farm in georgia
and uh
i put in 36 000 lay in chickens and
purina
promoted it and the price of feed went
up and the price of eggs went down until
every time i picked up a dozen eggs i
was making
i was losing five cents and i was losing
the farm
so i
started turning that chicken feed into
moonshine whiskey and i made a thousand
gallons a week and you can read over i
got all
they emptied their bullets at me trying
to kill me and blew my steel up and i
lost it lost everything so when i quit
running i was in california
so i went to work into construction
worked that a couple of years and then i
got on the redondo beach fire department
and so i was only five years
and uh oh it was a good job it took
it was hard to get on it's like winning
the lottery to get on it
but uh
i i had a little painting crew and i
have bringing antiques from missouri
back and selling them and i was making
quite a bit of money
and one day i was reading a national
geographic magazine as i bumped across
country with the other guy and it said
mercury in mexico was a dollar and it
was 13 in the united states and i said
i should bring some of that back when i
go down in my little airplane he said oh
man
you want to bring some of that marijuana
back i said nothing about it i heard
about the kid smoking it he said it's
the hottest thing you've seen what years
was it sorry 1973. okay
so all the cool kids are smoking that
marijuana we're just starting yeah so i
said well tell me about it so he
introduced me to a fellow said you got
an airplane yeah and he said would you
be interested what do you pay
so he says let me introduce you to
somebody so he called somebody and
fellow came over said i'll give you ten
thousand dollars and i said well throw
some of that hay in there
hey that's the nickname yeah i said well
yeah well i mean it looked like a little
bit of hay to me in the back seat of my
airplane it wasn't no big deal and i
come home and landed and give them their
stuff and they give me ten thousand
dollars in a bag and i brought it home
and shook it on the bed and the baby
got 100 dollar bills and crawling around
and my wife put her hand over her mouth
and i said let's go out to dinner you
know let's celebrate
so then i said wow now that i don't know
about that that wasn't nothing
so i went to a lawyer and i put a
hundred dollars to building his desk and
i said mr lawyer
what would happen to me if i got caught
bringing some marijuana across the
border in my plane
he said what's your criminal history
i said i've never had a speeding ticket
not even a parking ticket he said you
work on the fire department yes sir i
work
he said man you'll get probation
at the very worst
you'll get one year and spend four
months raking leaves
so i thought that's the business for me
so i bought a cessna 207 that would
carry 1100 pounds and i'm making 40 000
when i want to go down
so i brought my mother out from
georgia to disneyland and picked her up
my new cadillac and took her to
disneyland she said what you doing boy i
said
i'm holding pot ma you told her yeah and
she said how much you making i said i'm
making forty thousand dollars any day i
wanna go down there
he said what do they do if he catch you
and i told her what the lawyer said and
i said what do you think mom
she said do you need a
co-pilot and that makes all this sense
in the world that's that's family values
like goldfish absolutely were you giving
your mom money at this point uh yes i
took care of my mother i was gonna know
my family yesterday how different would
it been if mom said don't do it how
different would have been if she said
you shouldn't do it it wouldn't matter
it would have made a difference she
would have said it or not you would have
done it anymore oh yeah
why do you ask that because
parenting obviously i'm just curious i'm
curious to know if he was asking for
confirmation or if he was asking for
like i remember i was working at bally's
in chatsworth and
chatsworth at the time was 80 to porn
and the guy comes in with a pretty girl
and they're sitting there saying how
much money do these guys pay you per
month i said they pay me you know three
four grand a month he says how would you
like to make that every weekend i had no
idea what he was talking about
then he says uh uh he says well you know
you look like you'd make a hell of an
actor
i said really you've never seen me act
he said you just got the personality for
it i said great that's good they figured
me out in hollywood he said yeah
this is going so uh he says uh you know
you ever done adult films i said like
like movies for adult people likes you
know like ready rar he says no like
adult adult so what are you talking
about he says ponies and i'm not gonna
do porn he said well if you're i wanted
to we'd pay you four grand a movie
so after you did your first movie what
happened well i got paid four grand no
no but but i went home and i told my dad
i said dad so let me tell you what
happened to me today and then i told my
dad my dad's like if you ever do it yeah
you can never call me your dad again
really i said dad what are you going to
say if your friends see this thing
that's gabriel's son think about if your
older friend seed is they're going to
say that's gabriel's son wouldn't you be
proud of that he says no i don't want
you to touch itself no that's direction
you sought his counsel no i didn't i was
teasing oh gosh of course i was giving
him a hard time but that's the source i
was curious enough there was a
conversation with mom to see what mom
would say okay so he says so she says 40
000 do you need a co-pilot that's right
at any time you can go and make 40k and
come back
right so what do you do then you just
keep doing them keep doing them
i want to make 300 000 and go back to
farm and i got 300 000 right quick yeah
and my wife says you must not remember
like i do all that heat and bugs and
rattlesnakes hoeing and digging
she didn't want to go back so we stayed
instead what stayed in california in
redondo beach yes sir you didn't want to
go back to uh to georgia no you don't
want to do that okay your goal was three
hundred thousand that's what you said
and you got the goal bam and you said
and how long did it take to get that a
couple weeks months we could i break in
two or three months probably two or
three months so in three months you
reached your goal yes and you just
the taste of all that money was too
sweet to turn up you know turn up it was
just nothing it was just like there was
nothing between the united states and
mexico but a barbed wire fence i mean
and you couldn't even find that just
right i flew across real low and it
didn't matter so just coming just one
run after the other so was there a goal
to say babe once we make this much money
i'll stop or was it just a full-on
addiction to saying next one next one
next one let's get some more because i
know he said three hundred thousand
dollars and i would stop yeah well i
would have i mean my father went to the
farm but then you there and you're
sitting there with an airplane i'm still
working on the fire department i got
every four days off i'd go down there
and do it and come back and it was just
nothing it was absolutely just i'd go
down and go fishing
and
and your fire department guys are not
asking you they're like how do you
actually get that cadillac oh yeah they
reported me oh they didn't report you so
that's how it happened certainly well
that didn't that didn't matter
on uh
uh late load 13
i had that little feeling in my stomach
like ding ding ding this guy walking we
had to land at a i landed in a little
900 foot strip if you could call it that
on the end of a river in the sand and
there was water coming through and a
little waterfall and a river about knee
deep
and i'd go then brush my teeth and take
take fuel they had fuel and fill me up
and then the young fellow named uh
anyhow a young fellow would get in the
airplane with me
pedro
and uh
we would go over where he would tell me
to go on the highway maybe 20 30 miles
away and they had two trucks and machine
guns on it and i'd land between those
trucks and they had like a bucket
brigade they'd put the marijuana in the
airplane and i'd shake hands with all of
them and take off and they'd be 20 or 30
cars parked
waiting a highway patrolman in there
with no no light zone and i'd take over
that and go home and unload it
but on day 13 on the morning
we got in the plane
and pow
i thought a tire blew out and i looked
and he said please see it roger please
see it please see ya and it dawned on me
but we only had 400 feet from the end of
the runway
and i because i'd park down about
halfway
and just at daylight i just brushed my
teeth into the river and these men
around there and i just put it was a
cessna 207 a big big stretch cessna
and when i got to the end of the runway
i just pulled it up
and when i did there was four of them
that just
riddled that airplane with four ak-47
they put 80 bullet holes in it she hit
me across the top of my head knocked my
kneecap off and the end of my toe
and then shot his foot nearly off
and so i thought i mean
the windshield was all out and they'd
hit the tank up on the other side and
the gasoline was just gushing in on me
and they hit the uh strut right by my
head and the spattered is all in my face
hundreds of pieces of lead just
spattered all over me
and i thought i was going to die i
really did i thought i was going to
burst into flames with all that gasoline
and i just pulled the power and it went
went to hit that river and it looked
like
huge
turtles the way the rocks were formed i
remember
and when i hit the wings came off and
the next time the nose came under the
plane
and stopped in the water
and i was knocked out and he was shaking
me roger come on roger come on so we
jumped out and they were still shooting
the plane and come hit well on top of
the
um
on top of the radio i had taped in a
holster a nine millimeter
you were ready
no i just had that in case i crashed
somewhere you would like to have
something in the jungle if you i didn't
i didn't have it for people or nothing
just had something
kind of i don't know just like a little
survival kit self-defense yeah so anyway
i took that pistol and they was running
down the runway toward me and i shot a
few shots popped a few caps and they ran
into in the stones in the they were big
boulders everywhere and we started
running and i saw that pedro's foot was
nearly shot off
i mean it was just a
shot through the through then i took my
t-shirt off and it wasn't even bleeding
but it was just torn out i guess the
stress and we went up the hill through
the cactus and there was an old donkey
charlotte charlotte
and he caught that donkey and we got on
and rode roads we came to a little house
and
and there was some people they went for
help we sit there all day long
and uh that's that's a heck of a story i
can finish if you want me to then what
happened how did you get out of it all
right so i finished it then so there was
a little house and i see a usual in a
man plowing with a a cow and a an ox
a cow and a little mew
with a the harness over him and he was
plowing and so pedro talked to him and
they put us in the house and they the
woman put
uh cloth and put diesel fuel all over us
to keep the flies and the bugs off and
we sat there all day long
and about dark about 20 horses and mules
come into that yard
and there was a doctor there dr benjamin
so-so and he got in there and he i was
slugging my foot and he was trying to
find it and he gave us morphine and shot
us up and give us tetanus shot and
whatever
he said you got to get out of here they
got roadblocks everywhere looking and
they think the americans in here and
dead because of all the blood that was
in the plane
so
they put us on mules and horses and we
rode to a road did we come to a dirt
road and there was a big truck there's a
tin wheeler and it was loaded with corn
in the ear
and they dug holes in that corn and all
those mexican guys got on there with the
big hats and serapis and i guess it was
kind of cold and we put us under the
corn and that truck would just
and and the corn would fall over so they
kept pushing my face out
and we came finally to the highway and
they uh they got us out and we got
stopped three times by did you pay these
guys off no no they were just why would
it help you they just just wanted to be
helpful oh yes they just did they knew
who you were though did they have it
they had to do because but anyhow
they're wonderful people down in mexico
wonderful yesterday but they didn't they
knew you were on the run oh yes people
on the inside they knew all they knew
you were on the inside with who there's
a mexican cartel at this point no no
there was no such thing as that it was
just country folks just farmers and it
was growing pot and but these were just
people just helping us and that dr
benjamin so-so
but
they got a taxi for me to go to
guadalajara because he said they got all
the roads blocked north
so they got a dwarf guy to come and he
had a new car
and he talked and they propped me up
with the pills and uh
bandaged up and got some clothes for me
and i i remember that night we talked
all night long and again i said do you
have any children oh cesino i have a
beautiful wife and three boys
let me tell you how i got my beautiful
wife dora
he said you see me no girl would look at
me
but there was a girl in the village that
i had my eye on and she was playing in a
band she was playing the flute at the
back and i grabbed her and pulled her
into the yard and my mother helped us
get in the house
and i told her i love her and we sit
there all night but she wouldn't look at
us and the next morning senior we had to
let her go so she went to her father and
she knocked on the door and he said get
away from here you prostitute you've
been away all night with some man you're
not a daughter of mine and she walked
away with her head down and i said dora
let's go talk to the priest
and send you with that's how i go
to my marriage wow well i'm not through
let me just you just just just a little
bit more
and he said and then one year later we
had a beautiful baby boy
and i had a ford
and we named him ford
and the next year senor you won't
believe it but we had a beautiful baby
another boy and i had a dodge and we
named him dogs
and i know senor you won't believe this
but three years
though three years later
we had another young boy and i was
driving a new chevrolet and that damn
priest wouldn't name him chevrolet had
to teach him to drive to get him to name
him chevrolet and that's how i got my
three boys four dodge and chevrolet
unbelievable can you imagine any of your
kids after three cars it's kind of like
four brothers dallas denver
but
so okay so from there
you didn't get arrested you didn't do
time right away so what was the first
time you got arrested at what point was
the first time you you got arrested
after after i lost my airplane i uh
hired a man to fly another airplane and
he came down and i gave him five
thousand dollars and told him to land it
at a a
feedlot they're south of hermesa and he
mistakenly landed at the international
airport and tried to pay off and he had
my phony name in his pocket
and i was at the hotel a nice hotel a
guy nice gentleman came over and
arrested me
and they put me in jail there in
mazatlan in prison
and first time that was first time and
it was a terrible time uh
they wanted me to confess so there's a
bit of confession out of me so is this
the time they tortured you yes got it
this is the hot sauce story yeah this is
the hot sauce
you may want to tell the audience your
hot sauce story because i know you're
not a fan of hot sauce i have no story
so
you know first off they duck your head
into some sense of water until you just
and when you inhale it just explodes
your head
and then they beat you and
and after some days
and you they could took other people out
of the and you could hear them beating
and crying and beating them
and i was black and blue but it was no
more than a good fight you would have it
wouldn't bother me that bad
but they took me out naked and chained
me up and buttered my bum
and then they filled it full of hot
chili peppers holy moly
and i did talk ugly
i thought if i'll ever find you did that
ever like every time you go to a
restaurant and they say would you like
some hot sauce that i completely mess
with you for the rest of your life for
no i'm good on the hot sauce yeah you'll
leave it alone
well spicy food but there's a little
more to it then then they hung a dead
man in the cell with me
and it was just a little july and was
really hot
and the man was frozen and he was
wrapped in strips of newspaper like a
mummy
and
after a while the formaldehyde started
to melt and looked like he was crying
hanging on the meat hook and this opened
up so i could see his liver
and then the fluids start running out of
him went on the went on the floor and up
the place was not even six foot square
and i put my face under the door so i
could breathe
and as i breathe the fresh air i went to
sleep and i'm also breathing that fluid
that was in him and i had pink flying
pigs so i know where walt disney got his
ideas from
and when i came to i didn't know which
was real and which was a dream
so this this is the first time you were
arrested yeah and all these stories are
happening in mexico
yes correct so you haven't gotten
involved in colombia
many years i didn't get okay
so you're in jail the hot sauce story
the dead man in the cell
are you this like right now you're just
like this happy go lucky like zero
percent do i feel
drug smug smuggler criminal vibe out of
you whatsoever it's very apparent how
likable you are
or do you have the same demeanor at that
time of your life or oh no i memorized
his face and i was hoping to look him up
one day
so you're being serious
oh probably not but yeah i mean you just
do you're thinking that i don't know
what i'm doing to you surely but you
know what i'm saying about his
personality now you've interviewed
countless amounts of
let's just call them illegal
entrepreneurs yeah
his personality is not very common for
that type of that's a strength though
that's that's a very big strength
because you're
you know when when you're the guy
that it comes across as being harmless
he couldn't harm anybody that's the most
powerful guy in the room really oh my
god because they're so tight
i'm listening to him all i'm thinking
about his usual suspect yeah and all the
stories i'm like where's he picking up
i'm looking behind me thinking some of
this stuff is coming but obviously
you're a great storyteller and you know
that you're a wonderful storyteller but
so at this point
has the jail time have these experiences
99 of people if they had that hot sauce
experience the the the that you had not
hot sauce i keep saying hot sauce the
experience that you had
they're probably like you know what babe
i think i'm done yeah i'm gonna go back
to redondo let's go back to you know and
just kind of hang out why keep coming
back to it especially that close call
i don't know it didn't it didn't you
know when it was out the
um the the people that
where i was shot down from the load they
i had paid them 17 000
so they gave them money after a month or
so i got the word out
and uh
my wife came down and was trying oh oh
boy i mean she can tell the story about
going between those sales and visiting
me and the vis-a-vis day that's
where you have the little shacks you can
shack up with you with your woman in the
courtyard oh my gosh
so she's just walking straight with her
basket for food and them reaching each
side with her hands out
but anyway somebody come and pay the
seventeen thousand dollars
and i was taken out the back door of the
jail
and put into
a brand new pickup with a horse's head
only then taken to the bank and the
banker told me because he spoke english
that
this joaquin has paid them 17 000
roberto roberts has paid somebody in the
jail to get you out now that that's paid
for
and so when i caught that airplane it
was the fourth of july in 1974
and when them wheels came up i thought
before it really did get out of there
at that time how much money you have in
the bank
how much cash you got in the bank this
is 74. maybe half a million dollars half
a million dollars seventy four half a
million dollars like four million
dollars today three million dollars
that's real money that yeah i could have
retired but but did you but this this
story was prompted based on when i asked
you a question about the firefighters
the co-workers i don't know what what
prompted you telling that story because
what i was trying to find out is you're
still a firefighter in redondo beach
that the firefighters start realizing
why is this guy pulling up in a cadillac
what's he doing did they start asking
questions that they started reporting
was there an investigation or no they
played it cool i know that there was one
one fireman there that went to the
police or went to the dea i read read
that transcript
so so one guy went one guy did that do
anything did that need to do anything or
no i thought and and i really thought
for all those years that they had to
catch you
and they never did catch me
how long in u.s until they caught you
from 1973 oh they never did catch me i
was uh
for 12 years
i was until 1982
before they arrested me and they charged
me with continuing criminal enterprise
i was number 41 that was ever charged
with that horrible
charge it's the title 21 841 called
continuing criminal enterprise and you
have to manage three organizations with
five people in each organization and it
carries up to life in prison
and while john gotti was number 42
again you were 41 he was 42. yes and he
died in there i gave up the money
and
they dropped that charge and they gave
me um i think i
choose any two marijuana charges in in
income tax and i got a total of 35 years
with only five year sentence and 20 and
30 years of probation parole
so i got out after a couple of two and a
half years
caught out after two and a half years
and that's when barry seal
came to me i mean i'm skipping way ahead
and he says
uh i'm coming out tonight ronald
reagan's blue eyes was on the television
we have absolute proof that the
communists and easter government is in
the cocaine running business
and the phone rang and barry said i'm
coming out
but i come way ahead i jumped many years
in advance there telling that now for
people that you may not know who berry
seal silas if you want to put up the
movie american-made so they know what
movie
american-made played by uh
tom cruise did you see have you seen a
movie or not yes it's a great movie by
the way yeah i think so i thought it was
a good movie i mean obviously the story
of uh you're not a fan oh it was just
terrible
really oh yeah well of course you would
say that because because it's your life
meaning you lived it so you know more
details than the guys it was just stupid
like okay if you've got 30 million
dollars in your airplane you're going to
bet 10 he can't take off because the
runway's too short who could even think
of such a thing yeah you're gonna put
guns to his head and take his sunglasses
that's just pure crazy and then all
these planes running through the ipr
pioneered that course through the run
through the oil wells and they're gonna
talk to the dea how how are you going to
know what channel they own just like
it's going to go differently you're
saying a lot of that movie was just kind
of far-fetched i believe somebody
somebody said in a a rocking chair and
read something and said how could it
have been did you did you look at tom
and say he reminds me of barry or not at
all oh not at all really nothing barry
looked like
looked like a statesman barry looked
like um
somebody should have been a
governor or a senator like a clinton
like a bill clinton type of guy good
looking yeah and really smart well
spoken all beautiful smoking he's just
gentle and southern gentlemen nice and
managed you would have a mate
yes really
so so you guys you guys get hooked up at
this point who who has more power
and more money between the two of you or
is a different kind of power and money
very worked completely for me i paid him
a salary you so barry uh
worked for you you paid him a salary yes
and he's flying for you at this time
that's right okay we know that happened
but we got so many years we we jumped
over there so between those years of
jumping over what happened there did you
have any kind of connection at this
point from mexico to now you're doing
stuff with ochoa or pablo has anything
happened yet or not yet
no nothing's happened to them until i
guess 1980. but i i did uh oh i got a
twin beach airplane a friend of mine
says okay
you got shot down and you're shut up let
me buy you a twin beach they bought me a
beautiful one from i met the the beach
boys and bought their airplane that
thing was lovely
and uh went to atlanta and picked my
wife up and the red carpet was rolled
out and that thing was just absolutely
it's like that red one over on the right
but back then that was so nice
and i still like that best of all of the
airplanes i flew
and uh
yes and so then i could i could haul
about 2500 pounds and i just haul load
after load after load and they i started
operation star trek and they put these
trucks on the little hills all across
the border from
galveston to
tijuana but then i would go out in
middle of baja 400 miles south of san
diego and go out to a 300 miles and come
in behind the islands of santa barbara
and come up and go out in the desert
unload just never had any problem
whatsoever
so it looked like i had it's like i had
a license how many people were working
for you at that time nobody it's still a
one-man show just a one-man show so this
is
so always was this is still a one-man
show so at this time
um are you having the big life do you
live in a big house do you have the nice
clothes are you partying with the right
people are you being invited to
celebrities stuff like that i don't know
you're living a very low-key nobody
knows like the it's like the
millionaire next door or instead it's a
trafficker next door nobody would know
who you are is that kind of how it was
or not i don't know kind of a mix we had
a nice home in santa barbara you know in
hope ranch is really nice on what what
is what is that nice home mean to you
well it was 180 000 back then it's like
15 million dollars now okay so that's a
really nice source really nice oh yeah
50 million dollar home okay and uh
on a on a firefighter salary no well
listen i i quit the fire department and
we moved up to santa barbara my wife
found a house and i said you know we
can't
170 dollars how we gonna hide a house
she said we hide airplanes and ships you
can certainly we could have a house yeah
so
by the way this whole time you've been
with your wife yes same wife same wife
in and out of jail everything you've
been together 60 years 60 years strong
but we we're married 58 we were
sweethearts for a year and a half before
that yeah i know how it goes all right
and how much how much in that plane that
you mentioned how much money gets can
you you said 2500. 2500 tons pounds
pounds
2 500 pounds i apologize how what does
that equal in terms of what the weight
that you're moving marijuana and i was
making from 60 to 100 000 i flew it on
halves i didn't like to buy it or sell
it or load it or nothing i would i would
land somebody would put it in i would
come up kick it out somebody pick it up
and take it to him he didn't touch
anything
i didn't i didn't use it touch it buy it
smell it smoke it so did you feel like
you were a criminal at this point or is
it like look i'm not even touching it
i'm just the uber driver of the
trafficking business listen i never felt
like i was a criminal i'm an outlaw but
we outlaws for many things when you
break the law now it's not even against
the law after i got out after all those
30-something years there was a big
billboard said relax we deliver your
marijuana to your house
i think adam's trying to get ideas
that's what adam's trying to get ideas
on how to make that my next five minutes
who wants to buy that 50 million dollar
house in santa barbara i did
so okay so at this time you're you're
like you're living large are you
partying are you pretty located no party
in it you're not a part of an automobile
are you a guy that uses the product
smoke sweet snorts coke or no no don't
touch it you don't touch it you've never
touched it it's not touch it i tried but
i mean i don't but it's not something
you're like okay since i can inhale
yeah well biggie said never get high on
your own supplies that's right no i
don't i'm not a druggie i don't use it
yeah so okay so this is happening so are
are your are you still a middleman are
you still not working directly are you
still not somebody that's you know
or when does the big phone call come in
where you said oh shoot i'm officially
sitting with players in the room now
well i uh i'd like to back up and tell
you one story so i bought a dc3 and i
had connections down to columbia
to haul um to home marijuana in that
whole three three or three tons a
thousand miles and land on a 1700 foot
strip a wonderful wonderful airplane
there for that is would you pay for that
by the way that plane if you can put it
up john 65 000. you paid 65 000 for that
plane yes wow
and it's worth about a half million
dollars now
but anyway i was down there and and i
got shot down shut shot plumb i just got
by the columbian jet jets two jets that
was during the world series baseball
game in 1981
and uh i got out of that plane and uh
was 11 days in the jungle
and the other the other couple of guys
that were in the plane they went down
the road
and they spent several years in bogota
prison and i went through the jungle and
rode dugouts and whatever i could do and
swim across the rivers and i was 11 days
and that's when i uh finally came to a
place i could don just stall heavy on
square airplanes and the indians would
say loma linda loma linda
and finally when i got to loma linda it
was beautiful it was like hawaii and
world war ii airplane sitting out there
and i went up and
hello how did you get here you know and
and you don't know what this place is
this is la melinda headquarters for
missionary aviation fellowship for the
amazon and they flew me out
isn't that wonderful wow by the way
we have younger listeners this is not
the same amazon
like the amazon company you're talking
about like amazon amazon we have have to
clarify nowadays because some people are
thinking amazon was founded in the 80s
it's not folks it's later on so so that
happens and then what happens at that
moment how are you getting connected
with these guys
oh a guy came up and wanted me to know
if i would unload on a ship with
marijuana and wanted me to give him a
hundred thousand dollars or something
and to buy the fuel to come up in case i
didn't there so they could go back i
thought that was a pretty good deal
but it was just a rip-off so i went down
to see him
and uh
he didn't have the money of course so he
took me to see a man named fernando
correia
in medellin colombia and he was up on
the top floor
and uh
and he he looked like winston churchill
or was a kind of like he could speak a
lot of language probably a genius from
in no time but he was drunk and he
stayed drunk
so that's how and he said he paid five
thousand dollars a kilo
to anybody to transport his cocaine but
you see martha his wife and so i did and
and uh
so inside shader a woman from bolivia
sonia de attila
and
high cheek bones and rabbit boots and
rabbit fur coat and she was kissing him
on all cheeks and said she was going to
miami to buy an airplane
and so he said you have an airplane
don't you roger for sale
so the lawyer there did so i said yes
she said what kind i said a queen air
well she perked right up queen air
so she said the price and he kept
bumping his hand up like that
so i made a deal to sell her the queen
hair and i had it broke down
and then when it came to panama and she
said well you have to go to santa cruz
bolivia to get the money
wow so her entourage and all got in it
we went to santa cruz and the police met
her with the flags flying on the old
limousines and we went out outside of a
santa cruz and
to underneath the water tank and there
was like a house
made of marble square like a mausoleum
and there's a fence around it and the
people were all outside the fence and
they were crying
and she what's the matter with you fools
and you're lying is in there eating the
baby
she had a mountain lion and she opened
the door and run in there and there was
a kitty about a 200 pound mountain lion
eating a baby on the floor it almost was
i mean i won't it was just gross would
have been eating a baby the maid left
the baby on the floor in this mountain
lion that she's petting her house is
eating it
what
yes
that's the most gruesome thing i
horrible thing i've ever seen in my life
it was just just terrible
i mean she finally took it away but the
baby was eating done
some head and some diapers and family
left right there
dude that's a story it's just like yeah
so
holy mole well i guess i just took a
total turn seriously
i'm in a completely different place
right now
and it was her baby and her no no no no
right there when she pushed him away in
a blind line with all muddy mouth and
she grabs him around the neck and gets
him out of there and you know so roger i
i know we're going to get into pablo
escobar i know we're going to get into
some of those juicier stories
at any point you're already in a mexican
jail you're seeing babies getting eaten
you're getting your your your uh been
shot you've been shot at you you're
missing a foot almost
at any point you're saying babe like
is your wife not saying honey what are
you doing like just like live our life
in california or was the money too sweet
to pass up
did you know
looking at that time it didn't even feel
dangerous even those things happened
how's that possible i don't know but it
just didn't
what
you're seeing people lose their lives
you're almost losing your life and it
still didn't feel dangerous it it really
didn't i mean it's just like flying an
airplane and you land on a sand bed or
it's like a bush pilot it was fun and it
was great i mean go down and stay in the
nicest hotels in mexico and go fishing
and fly load back it was just great how
much how much [ __ ] did you see growing
up as a kid like did you live a rough
life like did you live a life where you
saw i lived in a
mother and father and grandma lived in
the ground
and it feels like you were raised with
right values i did yes of course i did
and then so as an outlaw yourself
you're you so you is so is it the thrill
is it the excitement is it money is it
let me get a little bit more is it what
what keeps you coming back
i don't know it was just it was just
like i wasn't i wasn't afraid of it and
it was a lot of money like now i'm
making 100 000 every time i want to fly
an airplane down for a little buzz and
go fishing and come back that was it
yeah
so okay so if you want to continue with
the story so at what point do you meet
ochoa or pablo
okay these guys uh come up after
i think it was after the dc3 was shot
down
and now i'm all right i can't go to
colombia and i've had some trouble in
mexico too there's things that i've
skipped
so
uh
i'm kind of out of places to go we went
to pakistan did a load out of there and
i did then went to thailand did a load
out of there big 20 ton loads unloaded
in british columbia flew it down in
float planes to washington state i did
what did the thailand deal make you to
20 tons
i don't know a couple of million dollars
i reckon you know couple million dollars
yeah i got bought a system 206 was a
beautiful plane and flew it down how did
they find you because this is this is
pre anything so how are people finding
you through what contest not like you're
on yellow pages it's not like you have
an instagram
me how are people finding you well this
guy
you know the thailand deal was later on
with a guy named howard marx that wrote
the book mr nice you've heard of him
yeah he hooked me up and uh got it did
several times so he's because obviously
back in the days in the military that
was normal so i'm thinking if the
connection was any kind of a military
things like this used to happen with
some of the guys that were in the
military back in the days military bases
were a great place to smuggle drugs
right back in the days oh he had some
people that were doing it we
had some people to do it but uh then
okay so a guy came up i mean uh
and wanted me to unload the ship and
then he stole the money and so i'm going
after it so he introduces me to uh
fernando caldero
and uh so then his wife says we're
having a uh his birthday party
and so it was over on the pacific coast
and this this is another
story so
i flew over there in a in a plane with a
commercial plane landed
on the pacific ocean it was like in the
jungle i mean it looked like you was on
as far away from
civilization you could get between
panama and ecuador
and they landed it must have been 300
people there
and that's when they was deciding i
think it was or i know it was the
beginning of the medellin cartel
they had ever actresses and actors and
stand-up comedians and judges and police
chiefs from all over and everybody had
their little bag of cocaine showing it
this and the other
and the party raged for about
two days and then the nice helicopters
went to flying away in the planes and
left us
poor folks there and for the
so it was sunday
and a good portion would be gone
and i'd taken some barbecue and went
around the log cabin and was laying
there in the
in the hammock reading mk's the fourth
pavilion and bow
and blood spattered on the book that i'm
reading
i rolled out of that cat out of that
hammock and kept rolling until i felt
safe to look up and i looked up and
there was a a young black man
a handsome man looked like he's about 22
or 25 and he was tearing the pistol out
of a
a colombian a white columbian man's hand
and he put it right between his head and
went click click click click there was
no more bullets in it and there was a
dog there a white bulldog with a
with a black spatch over his eye and he
was turning cartwheels and the blood was
flying
and i looked and on on the on the young
man was he had been shot in the in the
leg and he was bleeding bad
and i and so he hobbled backwards and i
said listen i told him in spanish i'm a
doctor i was lying but i could have
stopped it because with this fireman
training and
so he pointed that gun at me and i
didn't want that click click click in my
face and he hobbled on back and i said
please man i'm a doctor i can help you
and he went on back down there and died
an old crone out came out screaming
y'all people going to get in trouble
that night the generator went out it was
full of
water and
stuff when we went out there and we
could hear those people
under the trees down there
and we thought we was going to get
killed i mean sure enough and
the next day the place was the the
runway was covered in cans and trees and
stuff so that people couldn't couldn't
land
and we stood up all night long to uh our
little little
rags in the oil cans so we could uh have
a little bit of light
it's a crazy story but how did you meet
pablo so now then
i meet somebody there yeah and
and he wants me to fly cocaine okay
so his name was uh jaime ordonis
and he had had a ton of cocaine
confiscated him from him in medellin and
he had killed 16 judges
is what i heard
so
uh
i i flew down and uh he was supposed to
put 300 kilos and i believe there's 165
in there and i gave it to a guy named
bill barbosa and somebody shot him in
the stomach he was in the hospital two
or three months here in miami and i
thought
he won't fool those people anymore so i
told my friend mario the one that
introduced me to him
and uh
he uh he says i got somebody to
introduce you to i've got somebody you
need to meet come down
so i came down and we went to
in vegata as a village just out of
medellin
and
we pulled up into
a like a little estate like an old house
with hitching rails in front and little
stones all over and they must have been
30 or 40 men out there waiting to talk
to the
patrons
and so we was ushered right in and they
was a drop dead gorgeous woman in there
i mean she wanted to know if we wanted a
cup of coffee or tea so we had our
coffee and then we were introduced to
george ochoa jorge ochoa and he was
sitting at a big desk and he was so nice
he spoke some english and he had 12
telephones all of them were different
colors and he tell us this is new york
and this is washington and that in
seattle he said when it rings i know
where they're talking from so i got
salesmen in that part another and he
told me i want to know what kind of
airplanes i had and what kind of
experience i had crossing the border
and i told him and he said well we pay 5
000 a kilo for you to bring it up
and
we'll put it on and our people will
accept it up there
so he said let me get my partner
so he was going a minute and he came
back in with pablo escobar and pablo
escobar and a nice-looking man
friendly and had a nice attitude doing
them shook hands asked me the same
question did or he had asked me
he seemed pleased with it
because that was that was how i met met
him so i started flying
and they would put 300 they put 300
kilos on the first time
and then they i said it'll hold a lot
more but they wouldn't put it on for me
so after i don't know how many loads i
guess five loads or something i got
above the um
above the uh fog and i couldn't get down
and i had to land at
new orleans international airport and
bounce down that thing in the fog and
sit there
all night with 300 kilos in there so the
next morning the sun's come up and i'm
like ouch i
and i took off and and went over where i
was supposed to do and got down and i
thought i'm not gonna ever do that again
i had seven million dollars at the time
and i said i'm just i'm through so i
told leto the man that i give it to i
said listen man i almost got killed i'm
not gonna do it again oh roger please
please don't you know anybody
said that's when i hired barry seale got
it
and then i hired another fellow at
california and
so i had two airlines going and i had
about seven of those panther
conversions and
i had two people buying cars putting a
hydraulic jacks on them and new hoses
and new tires and
it was just like
bang bang bang bang so what do you paint
barry and what are you making every time
berry flies i would pay barry two
thousand dollars a kilo when he was born
five so he had five uh he made a million
dollars each time
and then i had to give him fifty
thousand dollars for the hefe
at mina
you have to give him fifty thousand
dollars said heffy at meena for people
that don't know who the hefe is is this
the william guy i suppose it was he said
i'm having good i'm he told him i'm
having dinner with the governor tonight
so i don't i don't know i never met the
governor
so you never met bill clinton no no okay
i've never even been to mena but but he
told you that this money was going to
bill no he told me i have it paid away
all the way to the top i have it paid
off completely there's no way on worth i
can get called meena and he did say a
couple of times i'm gonna be
i'm going to the governor of mexico now
where would you see him where would you
see him oh i saw him all the time i had
to get given him money all the time but
where did you see him all over the place
no i see him in new orleans or
he lived in baton rouge and he'd come to
miami and i'll tell you a little story
he he wouldn't fly again until i paid
him and it took me about three weeks to
get the pay because it was a pipeline
and so he would barely ache about it not
being any good natured really but uh
he's home he one night we went in the
room so he stayed with my wife and i and
the little baby in the in the hotel room
at the omni there and he hold the baby
up on his big old belly and oh ain't
that good rat and
so uh
i gave him a i paid him a million
dollars and i put up a package of state
free mini pads in there
and he liked that so good he made a
fought for it on his battlefield let me
ask you a question the story about meena
that uh at one point
mina a small city nobody knew about was
getting more ten thousand dollar cash
deposits than any other city in america
was that an accurate story they're
building banks on top of banks
and the federal government is like why
the hell does mina have so much cash in
the bank there what's going on over here
and it kind of triggered something well
i went to prison and i i was in there
for two years and then of course barry
was really nice he he paid me for the
airplanes every penny of it
uh that was and help my wife
whatever he could got me a lawyer so he
was a good friend of mine very well oh
yeah absolutely i love barry and uh
so then he started uh with the cia those
guys and he was
bringing it up by the tons and he was
landing in mina and he was taking a few
guns back down can you imagine what a
twin engine plane no matter how big it
is
ak-47 is gonna
affect the war down there
it was just an excuse for them to say
okay we're shipping guns down and
changing for this and
so that's that's all it was just the
front so it's just it's just a front but
what's what's the you know again you you
hear these uh like
when you went to jail when you went to
jail at that time when he was saying he
was paying all the planes and all that
stuff
how did you get caught for you to go do
the 30-something years that you did in
u.s not the 30 years but the time they
get caught here how did you get caught
okay just 11 people told on me and they
give
i think you could write a book of all
the depositions that they gave said
roger did it
the airplane on the man that worked on
my airplane he'd just tell about the
bullet holes in the plane see machine
guns in there which there was no such
thing white powder on the window seals i
never just they they once they get into
the grand jury they think they're going
to get out of their little problem they
just they just build
a a whole book about it
so
uh
the very
very uh the story about him being an
informant and working with guys and
being on the inside because barry
forward barry was more connected would
you agree that barry was more connected
with politicians and power players in
u.s
then you were connected in u.s and you
were more connected in other countries
than here is that the correct exactly
but barry was connected with the cia she
was connected with the ceo absolutely
they was
they was hooked up and they were
bringing it and they put the um
they had somebody to invent the crack
cocaine
and they put it in every city in the
united states over one weekend and it
killed thousands and thousands of people
they mixed it with i think bacon powder
or something and made it and it's
extremely addicting and went to the
black communities particularly what was
the motive behind it i mean we've read
about it i'm just listening just money
and so i mean on that one trip i know
that he brought one and a half tons in
and that's a pretty good solution i
understood there was 10 ton loads coming
in there
so
well there was so
the the the the story about
him uh uh you know
there's many versions of this story and
i've heard even you tell this story in
multiple different podcasts and things
that's been written about even in here
but
what are
rather than asking you what do you think
happened to barry and who killed them
what are some of the conspiracies out
there about who killed barry i know
exactly who killed barry you know
exactly i know 100 who killed him a man
named ronaldo
and on my second load
ronaldo got in the back i was on a um on
a banana plantation and it was real clay
long clay runway and i had a little
turbo jet arrow commander
turbo prop air commander and i took off
with him in the back seat with a mac 10
and when we took off the wheel wheels
got filled up with mud red clay and the
wheels couldn't come up
so i can't make it to louisiana
over 2200 miles i believe it was
so i had a place i used to refuel in in
belize and
and a real nice fella there on a huge
ranch so i told him we got to land he
put the gun to my head no no no you
you're going to louisiana so we're going
to all die you man we got to do it so
anyway we had a nice leonard went on and
he's the one that killed he's he met
barry i believe at that time
and he's the one that killed him he's
still doing life and uh he may have been
the one that killed him but was what's
his reasoning for quantic to kill
all those money i would imagine well i
don't imagine i just know that barry was
testifying against pablo escobar and the
old choice now this guy work for them
okay so there's no no question who who
did it
somebody paid him to come up here and
kill him and he had two guys with him
and they all got called is it true that
barry went to uh bush senior and said if
you don't clear up my irs tax issues
that i'm having you know i'm going to
let the whole story out and tell
everybody about what really happened
here what we did no that's not true
that's not true no okay he um
no that's just not true
got it so and then in regards to uh
bill clinton and i know it's probably
there's a lot of people to be
scared of in life
you know his wife's probably in the top
100 list for many people maybe not
yourself but you know she she's a pretty
experienced individual in many different
ways politically yes
um
who was bill clinton back then when you
were doing what you've done i mean i
know who he was but who was he was he a
power guy was he just a little you know
governor was he who was he he was a
strong man around meena there until he
was governor and then he was governor
and
that's that's just all it was that's all
i know did you did you also have those
kinds of relationships with other
governors from other states or no he
wasn't mean one thing i i would complete
that when i was doing
louisiana i used interstate 10 they were
building it and it was the best runway
you could ever see and the bridge was
the freeway oh my god you could land
what a freeway yeah and i just go out
there the next day and scrub my tire
marks out and
then they keep landing there you would
land on 10
interstate 10 before it was finished get
out of here all the way across louisiana
and texas as they was making it was just
beautiful we could have miles
have a truck there with a thousand watt
candle lights and was a game changer it
was one i know i mean you take it from
st augustine your neck of the woods
jacksonville all the way through florida
tallahassee yeah all the way through the
panhandle boom you're in louisiana or
mississippi louisiana texas you're just
in that bridge across the mississippi
several contractors went broke on it i
guess it was 10 or 15 years and they had
big red flashing lights just like at the
end of a runway and you had five miles
to the river in high school it was
beautiful
uh any any run-ins with the mob during
that time like when you were doing stuff
did you do anything with italian mob i
know you said 41 was you 42 was john
gotti
was there any kind of relationships one
day because when they find out somebody
knows how to make money they typically
want to team up did that ever happen no
nobody knew me that much but i i did
clean the russian grain ships with the
hydro blasting business and i met carlos
marcelo
and i liked him and he said now when you
do something that's how many knows it
and when you tell somebody that's how
many knows it how many is that
two no it's 11.
got it
like that then he tells his best
so that's what i remember he said that
yeah so what's the message there just
keep it just keep your mouth shut are
you telling your wife everything at this
point though
no but she knows what i'm doing but i
don't tell her and your mom knows what
you're doing she's over in georgia so
she's out of it she's gonna be she knows
they know she's aware oh yeah and your
wife's aware yes and at any point when i
i feel like i'm keep circling back to
this you're getting shot you're getting
run up on you your plane's going down i
mean you're going to jail hot sauce at
any point is your wife saying honey
enough's enough
are you that big of an adrenaline freak
are you that just hey you know it
happens the line of business to get out
of this i don't know she just she just
had faith in me she just believed i
could do anything i mean it's like i
always came home
and uh
and she knew about where i was and she
was kind of my flight plan
so
sometimes i remember by eating
sandwiches and i'd have a love letter
right in between the bologna you know so
did she love you that much or did she
love the 15 million dollar house she
definitely
definitely did not love the money and
still doesn't huh she does not she's
real simple she's a very christian
person we both are christian but she's
really
she really really loves the lord did you
ever try to introduce jesus to pablo and
and tell pablo about jesus and god and
bible or no did you sit there no no you
i'm not talking about you oh no i don't
i'm not i'm not that that type of a
person so so how much total time did you
spend with pablo and ochoa
if you were to i spent a weekend with
ochoa out there with his uh out on his
uh were they all all the bird cages and
the animals and all that and uh with
with uh pablo i i spent like a i saw him
like three times or four times and i
spent one day with him we flew out to a
farm that he had in here with a couple
of guys in it and there was some boys
there and they put me on a motorcycle
early in the morning and wet with grass
was wet and he said you ride a
motorcycle like yeah so we got on my
boom boom boom and i went and there was
a little ditch there and the front wheel
fell in it and i went sliding across the
grass and they all had a big laugh you
know and
so then uh we rode those motorcycles wow
and then we got on horses and he gave me
a machine gun pistol and over can you
you know about this and of course i've
never seen one absolutely so we we we
rounded up some cattle played cowboys a
little bit
and um what's he got was either one of
them the type of guy that you see him
you're like wow what a fun guy what a
nice guy and then all of a sudden
something happened triggered boom it's a
completely different human being or is
it what your few hours that you spend
with them you just saw one uh side of
their personality oh i i think that he
was just one side of his personality at
that time i think he went somewhat crazy
you know they had a there was a
three-prong war down there for some
years and 10 000 people a year being
killed murdered in medellin so
the
the
military was just as bad the government
just as bad as his side you had the
government
you had the conscious that was
the white colombians it was against the
guerrillas and all three of them was was
full on in the cocaine business and into
tons of it
and so i i guess uh
the contras was who i was working with
but there was plenty of it coming out
from the from the jungle from the
from the farc
and the military was producing and
robbing and stealing all they could get
so it was fair game
so i guess whenever they started killing
pablo i don't know who started killing
first but it was a war between them
and
so people get
when people start dying around you and
people trying to kill you
people change
and and i believe he did and later on
he'd become like like a monster just
bringing that airline down if he did and
paying a thousand dollars for every
policeman that they would kill and
that's just that terrible didn't know
cho go and turn himself in and then he
did like five years and it came out and
now he's like living in america i think
he's still alive or something like that
right yes
his older brother died recently right
and his younger brother just got out of
prison i believe what is he up to what
is ochoa up to he has a place for
pasacino
pacifina horses there in uh in vegato
he'd be a very i think we reached out
for an interview a few years ago he'd be
a fascinating guy to interview you know
to if he's still a medium you think he
would do an open uh he would do an
interview i don't know he's a mighty
nice person he's a real gentleman
so he's not a guy that's killed anybody
you know
just not not his type of person at all
you like him oh sure yeah so i'd be safe
if i want to make the internet
well maybe we'll go together because you
got your license back he owes me some
money so you don't want to talk to me he
owes you some money three and a half
million dollars so maybe we go collect
and go house that's good i'll show you
that's what he's trying to get i mean
adam's trying to this entire time he had
a only fan situation that we're trying
to fix and you're you're i know you're
kind of joking no i'm not waiting no no
no no i know pat's kind of joking but
he's also kind of serious because look
at
uh his resume how many mafia mob guys
have you interviewed
dozens yeah countless yeah how many guys
affiliated with dea escobar
you know everyone in the colombian
mexican cartels i mean and we're talking
dozens and dozens and dozens of this
what keeps coming why does it keep
coming back to you like all right these
types of characters these stories these
entrepreneurs doing things their own way
why do you keep revisiting this what is
it about this and what is it about their
business models that maybe you learn
from yeah i mean for me like i am
as much as i love capitalism i like
talking to communists more because i
want to know
what makes you believe in that argument
makes sense like as much as i'm a free
enterprise guy i like to talk to like
jenk is one of my favorite guys i talked
to what makes you believe that like what
caused you to get there
i'm a
law abiding citizen but i want to know
sammy how did you get here sammy to
belgravano i'm just curious what was the
tipping point was there a place to
save you from getting there like with
him
it's it's either you are
uh uh you know who you look like can you
pull up jim jenkins this entire time you
know who jim jenkins is or no okay so
type in jim jenkins and
uh uh type in jim jenkins and put uh um
kennedy right next to it put kennedy
right next to jenkins yeah uh
right there look at that okay click on
that
jim jenkins was one of the autopsy guys
you look like you guys could be brothers
by the way obviously he'd be older than
you but jim jenkins he's a handsome guy
by the way what's crazy is he's been
married to the same woman for 50 plus
years so similar how many how long
you've been married to your 58 years 50
he's been married to his wife at this
point i want to say 54 years 55 years
right
you have no idea who this man is jenkins
okay uh no but i sit there and i'm
listening to to you and i'm like okay
uh
do you think
you're smarter than the people you sit
with like do you think you can outsmart
and outmaneuver yourself out of anything
do you think that or no not at all at
all no seriously no so would you
consider yourself a very simple man yes
what do you like to do for fun i like to
walk i like to run i uh climb the
mountain behind our house every every
week and
that sort of thing how about when you
were 35 like what was fun for you at 25
or 35
oh i don't know i i like flying and uh
i like
with my wife and i would go out to eat
dinner and bottle of wine that sort of
thing we didn't do anything i mean uh
just didn't have anything
to travel in your simple life and are
you somebody that if somebody shared a
secret with you it stays with you
absolutely that's that's your uh mo it's
strong and it stays with you so then
because the fact that you're alive still
sitting here and barry is not
means something there was something that
happened there that they weren't willing
to take you out or
they had no reason to whatsoever i mean
it's not about that many different
reasons to take you out if i got a plane
you're bringing me a delivery and if i
want to flip against the other guy
and i can just take this there's a lot
of different ways i can
eliminate you the people could do that
to make more money a guy like you no no
you misunderstand
they put i'd land a plane on a i would
come over el banco
in magdalena basin yeah and i'd be at
ten thousand feet whatever kind of
airplane i had and i'd look at nine
thousand feet and there'd be a cessna
tail dragger bush plane so certainly at
9 000. i didn't know where i was going
and i'd circle around i'd find him and
we wiggle wings and i might go 100 or so
miles behind him and we'd come to a
jungle strip and i would land
and i could spend the night i could do
as long as i wanted to they they'd have
a good meal for me put gasoline in the
plane fill it up with the cocaine and i
would fly back and each one of those
duffel bags belonged to someone
and they would have uh
like the brand for their cattle
like a snake on it or three x's or or
some horns and those all belong to and i
would give them to a man in miami here
that named leto
and i would just point out the cars
where they were
and
i didn't i didn't
they didn't have to give me any money
i'd wait three weeks sometimes a month
before i get paid
yeah but but the moment people know on
the inside and greed happens how do
empires fall they fall within it within
you don't have to ever worry about the
people on the outside always worry about
people on the inside that may turn
against you due to envy or whatever
maybe
all i'm saying is somebody on one guy's
side says hey
uh you know such and such you know this
guy making all this money why don't you
and i go
and be in the middle of the travel that
he's doing and take him down and take
some of this stuff and we can walk away
with a couple million dollars temptation
happens and that happens all the time
that's what i mean when i say i don't
know the fact that you're sitting here
you know somebody
looked over you because exactly odds are
not supposed to be
on your side
in regards to el chapo el chapo is a
1957
guy you're 1973 when you started so he
was 16. so you've probably never done
anything with el chapo or any nothing
not at all because he came later on
got it and so
outside of that with pablo and ochoa
you you've been very complimentary about
pablo but at the same time you said when
i found that amount of people he killed
i you know i was disappointed by that
what's your relationship in how you
summon how he treated you to what he did
later on how do you view pablo is it
like a complicated way you view him
no i just think that he just turned bad
did he just probably the stress or
whatever it was and you people start
shooting and killing each other people
it's like him war look what's happening
now with putin and you wouldn't think
that about him
a couple of months ago seeing him but he
turned and killing tens of thousands of
people
do you think uh
good men
are
capable
of i guess the question will be the
following do you think more
of good men are capable doing evil
things or evil men are more capable of
being good wow
i don't know i think all of us all of us
could do bad things if not if we had the
right provocation
and i think all of us want to do good if
we just living and be around us and
people are nice to us and you say hello
and good morning and we i love everybody
where somebody's killing my family i
turned into something different
yeah i agree i wanted a conversation
with my dad and i told my dad i said dad
do you think you're capable of killing
someone he says never i said that stop
this is never i'm telling you i could
never do it you meet my dad my dad you
know
you know yeah he's i'm not capable of
doing something to anybody i said that
stop it i said take one your grandkid
somebody does something to him right in
front of you
if you have a choice between killing
them or what would you do he says
well maybe i'm capable of doing
something
life changes a little bit right when you
get to that but uh have you seen evil
evil men become good
no no no
have you met many evil men throughout
your lifetime yes in prison there's
something should be executed seriously
absolutely tell me more
well we had a fellow in there named
stick them
and stick them steve was a guy about my
size but i i think he'd kill thirty came
in to do three three years and he killed
13 people while he was in there
13 people in there in prison over the
years he'd go in a year or two in
solitary and he'd get out and he'd kill
somebody else maybe he wouldn't get get
convicted of it he killed somebody else
and then he killed somebody else so
prisoners yeah
and for what reason whatever just didn't
bother him so he come in we had a little
tv room there long park is a maximum
security prison where somebody was
killed every month when i was there
murder every every 30 days somebody was
killed what city is this long park
california here okay
they got cameras in there knocked it
down to three or four years but when i
was there it was bad
so steve would come in
turn the television camera at three
o'clock we had
headphones to plug in in a
little tv room glassed in you all know i
watched bananas every day at three
o'clock and the guys would just lay the
headsets down and go like i wasn't
scared of steve i still want to kill him
i didn't want to trouble with him so i
just put my headset down and watched my
nails on one of the other
well i was down on
cell 17 and my friend phil was 18 and i
was a little slow getting my cup of
coffee my coffee to go down to the end
to the with the hot water heater wasn't
really 15 or 20 men down there getting
it
and my friend phil's coming down and he
says and i'm going he says you don't
want to go down there
what's going on phil he said you don't
want to see
[ __ ] i do want to see and i go down
there there's nobody there it's placed
bigger than this room
and i look and i get my hot water in my
instant coffee and i look across and
there's steve
with his shirt off
at the rail
and he turns around and comes to me and
it looks like a car spring has been
stuck through him all the way through
his chest and it's out his back
oh boy
and he come right up to me and like a
little boy says
can can you help me
can you can you help me
i said no steve i don't buddy i don't
believe i can help you and he said can
can anybody help me
and he walked back over to the rail and
he leaned over and the blood started
coming out of his mouth and dropped down
by the guard station and of course the
guard hit the button and here all the
guards come 50 of them and they're going
up them stairs shaking it like boom boom
boom boom
and his boss he painted painted the
house and his boss was a tubby fella
about 30 years old and they had had an
argument the day before and he almost
put steve into choking
and he ran right up to steve and he was
like me he didn't see it to start with
him when he saw it
he dropped dead of a heart attack right
in front of steve's feet
get out of here i'm around the corner
kind of having a look and all those
people and then steve fell down on him
just the two of them did right there
together
and they locked us up for two weeks and
i mean they treated us bad they come to
everything out of the cell
with guns in my face like say something
reef say something who's they who was
what that guard his name was clark
but what did what did stick him steve do
at that point where he just he just fell
dead he just no but who did he kill at
that point he didn't kill anybody
somebody had come into his cell while
he's still laying on the mattress and
put that up put that medal through him
it went out into his mattress threw it
through him and he didn't kill him right
then he lived another five minutes so he
his was the first cell there on that
side and so he just walked out and how
many different prisons have you been in
but wait i want to stay on the story
here so this guy
so did you guys finally find out who
killed the guy no nobody wanted to know
who killed him how many people wanted to
sell in the prison with you guys at that
time 1400. oh so you're not going to
find that about 200 in my unit and i was
a maximum unit there was some bad boys
in there
well you're saying steve had it coming
absolutely 13 people you're kidding me
every time he goes down there so so
eventually
somebody is going to take this guy out
but somebody should have done it a long
time ago somebody did a long time ago
the government should have done it i
mean why we're going to show you you
believe in death penalty 100 when i went
in i didn't but after living with some
of those
people that
black bob cut a man
open and ate his heart and put him under
my bed knee seventeen before i got there
what yeah so i mean you live with
somebody cut a guy up and ate his heart
he cut his heart up he killed him he
couldn't what jail did you go to like
this this is this is in california
long penitentiary
right there fourteen hundred men twelve
dying a year average that that's why i
asked the question about how many
different jails you've been to and what
was the worst i got it so you're trying
to compare like how bad yeah compared to
this yeah
you've been to mexican jail you've been
to jail in california i assume you've
been to jail you've been in jail in
australia 26 of them how many different
jails and what's the worst situation to
be in in mexico okay by far no no doubt
about it this is cleaned up somewhat now
uh than than what it was there's where i
was 11 years
or maybe not you look at it right now
what do you think when you see this
picture does it do anything to you i
just think what a terrible situation the
united states has all those men in there
half of them don't belong there
half of them don't don't
don't belong there yet but so go back to
death penalty and i want to ask you the
question on the half and half so that's
been enough you're fully forward you
went in not being forward you're yeah
you're left saying no we we need that
penalty there's some people in there
that you know like black bob i mean he
would just he'd just kill you if you
fool with him and you just like i don't
know he played and he had shot heroin up
and and uh he had plenty of sense i
played that chess almost every day and
he'd be nodding off and i said come on
bob move and he'd move and make
okay and beat me and so he ain't no
shortage but
to do something like that and he's in
there for murder
did any of that so did you go in
uh as a simple guy did you come out with
some bad ugly uh um maybe not habits but
like your view of the world and your
intentions changed where
you could do more harm than you went in
or you went in you came out the same
human being
i think i came up pretty much the same
thing but i i mean i got tougher
as the years went by in there yes you
see it these teeth are not my own
i left them in a man's neck
what happened there he was winning
okay i got
he had his hair and i pulled it over and
gave him a good bite and that was the
end of that did you do that right after
seeing the tyson fight or was it like
inspiration came from i should give him
i should give him some lessons
even after the year you went up to the
head
do you think it's
there must be some i know you said i'm a
simple man you know i'm just here yeah
there must be
deep below maybe not on the surface
maybe something you don't even like
talking about a deep sense of
cunningness
a an acute sense of not at all
there's got to be something in there
you're hanging out with pablo escobar
with the choa you're hanging out with
these literal murderers but yeah you're
just they weren't then they were just
like us sitting here absolutely you
can't look at a man too but even in
prison though roger well one of some of
those people that guy something bob you
said what did you call him black black
bob black bob do you think he was always
evil yes
so you think some people are well known
listen no little babies born evil
no i get that but do you think like he's
been bad for a long time i don't know
what happened to him to make him that
way but from from you being around them
i'm just curious analyzing some of these
guys how much of that is parenting how
much of that is their own dna
there's a bunch of their own dna because
it follows i succeeded in families
grandfather father son comes right on in
there
that's what you're going to pass it down
look at animals
you've got you've got bulls that hook
and gore you get rid of them
and in person you heard
uh
gets gets a better disposition it's
crazy to know that the perspective here
to believe in death penalty after seeing
what many of these guys did so and did
you ever see
well you said no you didn't see
you said half the people in america
shouldn't be in jail the ones that are
in jail shouldn't be in jail the other
half deserve to be in there how do they
end up in there how broken is the system
that we have
it's horribly broken why and how
okay a lot of the people in prison not
in those prisons but in the lesser
prisons making up the population and
camps and farms and this
a de ager to go under the bridge with
his mustache and his uh
tattoos all over him and he'll shoot
harem with these guys or he'll snort a
little bit of whatever
and
he'll get one of them
two or three grams of methamphetamine to
the other one and now he's got two busts
and he takes them to jail
and boy now i've got two so he does that
every month or two so whenever it's come
for who's gonna make sergeant guess who
makes sergeant the one that's got all
these little arrests
or maybe someone a little bit bigger but
i'm just just making
so now then he goes to a young
prosecutor and the prosecutor comes to
say but we're going to give you 10 years
if you don't plead guilty buddy
and you've got a public defender
i'm going to make sure you do 10 years
if you'll take five
you can do it now the prosecutor says
okay
and it's full of them okay you're gonna
have to do four on the five
and so he's had two grams of
methamphetamine
and i'm i've been waiting on a parole
hearing in oklahoma city
which i'm not ever which i never got
and
so i meet a fellow from
santa barbara and where are you going he
said i'm going to atlanta i got caught
with two
two grams of methamphetamine and i'm
going to atlanta for
psychiatric evaluation
and then i meet a nice young fella from
albany georgia where are you going he
said i'm going to los angeles i got
caught with two grams of methamphetamine
i'm going for psychiatric evaluation i
imagine they cost the government thirty
thousand fifty thousand dollars to take
them across country and leave them a
month in oklahoma city at the big big
exchange there 17 planes i believe i
don't know for sure which [ __ ] uh
fed air
con air don't ask who owns it
hey some
now the people of the government and
people the united states don't want to
pay that
it's these people they're lining their
own pockets with it in their own
retirements and it's it's wrong it's
really wrong
so
your upbringing could they have done
anything for you to not not have pursued
this career your parents yes i um i
don't blame it anybody's home it's all
mine but my father was an alcoholic okay
and we lived in a nice white house on a
pretty big farm but he was drunk
and he loved us and nothing wrong with
him he was just a gentleman but my poor
mother worked in the sewing factory and
dug like crazy in the dirt and
and made us helped us make a living
and i think if he had to put his arm
around me and said son you know you're
smart why don't you be this or that or a
lawyer or doctor or whatever
i would have perk right up because
whatever he said uh
i like to do it but he said roger's the
best damn hog catcher in the county well
i was sure i was
i'd wrestled a bull down or ride a
bucking horse and i mean he laughed
about that and and i liked it so i just
wondered my daughter's a doctor and i
encouraged her you know study a lesson
you'd go for something you can do it
so i i think but he never beats you up
he never did anything he wasn't he
wasn't like he was abusive he just drank
he was a wonderful human being i i if i
talked about him now i'd cry
but you were seeking his approval yeah
if he told if he told you to do
something positive in your life you
would have done that oh yes of course i
would have been power of a father
however
well can you can you go a little bit
more deeper on that the power of a
father on the son why is that rule so
important well it is why why is it so
important i think it's just we seen
bread in us what our fathers and mothers
think of us it really is particularly
boys with their father
i mean i can remember things that he did
and it just warmed my heart when i was
about five or six years old i'd follow
him and he we had two bird dogs and he
would shoot the quail with a double
barrel shotgun and they'd point them and
then as they fly
and the birds of feather would fall and
the dogs would get them and come here
and then i said daddy can i shoot that
gun you know and he
he says do you really want to shoot this
12-gauge shotgun i just little
yeah i want to shoot it so he puts it
over a stump and he gets behind me real
close and holds me and he puts it in my
shoulder and he pointed to that tree and
i pulled that trigger and the bark flies
off of that pine tree man i could have
walked on the air i was so big you know
stuff like that it just uh do you
remember that vividly vividly
i remember me out in the yard and i'm
throwing a butcher knife up in the
leather wing bats i think i'm going to
hit them because they'll dive towards
you they're blind and they go away and i
see him coming down the road with his
leather coat on and a double barrel
shotgun over and his two big rabbits
hanging in i run all the way out and
meet him can i carry one and i have to
hold it up like this and the rabbit's
hair you know you just remember things
like that and and
and then for him being drunk if he would
have been carried on with that what
would i have been i would i wouldn't
have never went to prison but it's
certainly not his fault it's mine i
didn't
my brother didn't go to prison my
children my sisters didn't
so you don't put any of the owners by
the what month's your birthday january
the 26th
aquarius wow and then how about your dad
uh
april april
pat this is something that you're
you constantly are kind of bringing up
the role of the father the role of
the role that you play with your kids
the important role that your father has
played in your life yeah something that
even when roger over here is talking
about his dad this is something that
interests you greatly like he said he's
going to get emotional about this
even with um
with uh rick macy we talked about the
role of a coach and the role of a parent
and role of a father what is it about i
mean other than the obvious of obviously
your parents are important what why is
this something you keep bringing on
harping about yeah i i i just think you
know
um
[Music]
you know we're trying to fix
you you're getting to the product late
to fix it
you know i don't know how to describe
that like
we're trying to fix the product
after it's already been broken for 18
years amen instead let's work on the
most important example and
you know
face of what that product is looking up
to and who is emotionally listen
i i you know i have a lot of influence
okay so i went to um a wedding you know
with this this uh one of our guys
george's wedding
and uh his dad and i we've had a lot of
good battles back and forth a lot of
them over the years dad was a man's man
just like uh he was a guy cuban guy you
know tough guy you know confident
swagger walks in not afraid i took him
to kentucky every one time
and you would have thought he owned the
derby how he was and this was like 10
years ago when i took him to the derby
and 11 years ago when i took him to the
derby
but he would be like why are you making
my son do this you're making him drive
from palmdale to this and papa we would
get into it i'm like listen
i'm not trying to do anything about your
son trying to help your son be a man and
a leader let me do my part let me do my
part right
and
son george is a quality quality guy very
quality guy right smart guy very success
he runs a 30 million your business with
us right now does very well for himself
but uh
he wanted to win for his dad right and
his dad comes up to me to the wedding in
november when he got married i'm here i
think november 13th or something like
that i'm in a beautiful wedding small
wedding but a beautiful wedding my dad
is i got to talk to pat i got to talk to
him we go in the corner says hey listen
to me you need to know this you need to
hear from me because there's only one
man that can tell you this i said what's
that he says my son's had two fathers me
and you
we've
raised this boy together i got him in
the first half you got him in the second
half but it's you and i and he's crying
i'm crying my body's got chills all over
you know i'm feeling it right now
but a
boy wants to make his
dad and his mom proud and some of that
[ __ ] breaks and he just i don't know so
yeah to me i would much rather train the
trainers i would much rather get the
parents i would much rather get the
fathers then we get them at this point
of the game it's too late absolutely
it's too late what are we going to do in
here at this point so we screwed the
whole thing up way too late will occur
i'll tell you how to do it
let's have from starting off that's how
family planning is a great great part of
the eye education
did you know that there's a half a
million children in foster care and i
don't how many in in orphanages
and millions aborted every year but
those children are unwanted no one loved
and they wind up there
a great portion of them
don't know who their parents are don't
know my mama didn't want me
and and i think i told this before my
daughter was
my daughter's a doctor and she delivered
a baby to a 10 year old child
what in the world i mean what
what four four or five generations in
the in the vision room all on welfare
and and i say that a bird builds a nest
before she lays an egg not so human
beings and where the children are
are
rather more scarce
they're wanted and they're loved and
they're taken care of and nurtured and
that that's what needs to be done
you know the four things i i tell my
kids is lead respect improve love
yeah and and uh i don't know
i don't know a a
co-op listen everybody talks about it's
not like this but it's not like the way
you sell it i don't think the power of
love man that love is a very very
uh you know challenging thing
unfortunately we had paul manafort here
last week i don't know if you know what
paul manafort is paul manafort went to
jail trump you know that whole situation
as a lobbyist trump's campaign yeah and
and i'm not i'm not a fan of lobbyists
at all and i told him i'm not offended a
lot about what these guys do right it's
a big business model you make a lot of
money but then he said something he says
what are you gonna do okay don't have
lobbyists the other side's gonna have
lobbyists so don't go and have them so
now what are you gonna do and you're
cornered
so yeah oh you know what we're not gonna
use tanks but they're gonna use tanks
okay let's get a couple tanks guys you
see what i'm saying for sure hey hey
they're gonna use uh
rocket launchers no no that's not our
policy no we got to get rocket launchers
guys let's go buy some rocket launchers
right so eventually
to go against an enemy that's doing that
you know you you you try to use love as
much as possible but some people are
just they're playing by different rules
than you so you as a human being are
conflict conflicted constantly
conflicted to say
what should we
use to handle this crisis okay should we
handle it you know just let it go and
don't worry about it well then if you
let it go in the market gets a
reputation of you just let things go
then they're going to come in like
vultures you know take advantage of you
constantly then what do you do
and maybe that's not the responsibility
of everybody maybe that is the
responsibility to parents to impose that
love and
respect and strength and confidence on
the right values and principles and
hoping the kids are going to pick it up
and do something with it you still got a
risk because at the end of the day i
think the kids got to do what they got
to do there's a lot of kids that were
raised to great parents that did some
dumb [ __ ] they did some stupid things so
a part of the onus is going to be on
them as well you can do everything right
and still screw it up because
you are not seven and a half billion
people around your kids and you're not
around them 100 you know percent of the
time you only run them for a few
hours or minutes or sometimes they're
gone away from you when they're adults
but yeah i think uh
adam to go back to it man
um
i think somehow someway
as much as we are doing what we're doing
with parents
you know with kids
i think there's got to be some kind of a
parents once a week once a month course
teaching something
i don't know because if you do it and
they do it the kids feel it
if you pick something up and somebody
tells you here's how i raise my kids and
you do it your kid is going to be the
beneficiary of what you picked up from
another person that taught it to you i
think we're not spending enough time
teaching parents i want to keep saying
this i think we're not spending enough
time teaching parents but i think you
know parents are also starting to
realize a few different things but all
the stuff that's going on disney netflix
politics you know all this mess that's
going on parents are starting to realize
uh i have to be more involved there's
four things we came up with today one of
them is they're going to start putting
their kids in more private schools
because right values and principles are
necessary number two is homeschooling is
going to increase number three is
they're gonna relocate to different
places could be a state they're gonna
relocate to a different place and number
four i'm gonna keep saying this to you
and i'm not even in the business i'm
telling you right now
you're gonna see
more
parents putting kids in churches
some kind of addition like like mma my
kids go to the bar here in fort
lauderdale
and
i gotta tell you they're sitting there
teaching them discipline that's not how
you do this you respect each other you
do this you have to put your kids in
communities right now that are teaching
the right values and principles whether
it's martial arts whether it's church
whether it's sports whether it's
anything because
there's a lot of it's almost as if
there's a lot of people that are also
confusing kids nowadays where parenting
matters and supporting cast matters
but i'm listening to you the entire time
when you listen to him if you close your
eyes you didn't know a story and we
never talked about him being a smuggler
and all we were able to talk about is
from zero to 18. and you have one game
you have to play can you guess what he
ends up doing for the rest of his life
would you have been able to guess what
he did for a living
definitely not a drug smuggler based on
his would you have been able to guess it
today he's just a guy who likes to fly
and happen to have drugs on the plane he
became a pilot maybe him a fighter pilot
maybe he went into the military became a
you know colonel lieutenant something
like that he said initially he wanted to
be uh
a missionary missionary aviation yeah
that's where his heart is yeah and it
just so happened that the money was too
sweet and it regrets
pardon any regrets oh
33 years of them
yeah we knew nothing and nothing nothing
in this life we have law and people is
aware but no no amount of money is worth
going to prison for
not for long
not like that
why though i mean you kept going back
though
why i mean you went to you say that but
i mean i hate to do this to you he asks
you the same question three times
you say no amount of money is worth
thirty three years ago went to jail 26
different times in six different
countries on four different continents
and escaped five times like i wanted to
get home
okay well
all right i when i got
35 years for marijuana yeah and i got
out after a short time and had 30 years
of parole
and that means anytime you violate they
can give me all a part of that 30 years
it was lame
now then you get very sealed it comes
says if you
and they let me tell you about that
after i saw reagan's blue eyes on the
television
but saying that the communist sandinista
government was in the cocaine running
business and there was barry's
airplane
building on the runway in nicaragua
uh oh and i'd heard barry might have had
turned so i got a phone call from barry
and he said i'm coming out tonight he
said i'll meet you at a
french restaurant in in santa barbara i
don't remember what it was
so i'd be there at nine o'clock so i
came in and barry had gained weight and
he was back at the ball and i looked
around there's about 20 25 people in
there women with leather skirts on all
30 40 years old
men blue jeans and jackets
you know
and i went up and barry
are you wired and he said no i'm not
and i said well uh of the old dea and he
said every one of them
and i said well please just tell me what
what's going on
and he said then he leaned back and he
started telling me how that how did it
happened and how that
he got left holding the bag
and he just put his hands between over
his eyes and the tears ran down between
his fingers said roger i just couldn't
do it i just couldn't do it i was facing
three life sentences life sentencing
each prison in state florida
uh i don't know where louisiana and
arkansas he said so i went to
i got out on bail and i went to see
edwin meese
in washington and i told him everything
i i've testified before congress and i
told him your part
and uh
and
you testify with me you can keep your
money you'll get a new passport your
family live wherever you want to live
so he was one to 11 people
you know he was i think 12. that was
after i'd already gone so he said but
you've got to do it he said i just
couldn't do and i'm so sorry
so he brought
the guy said wouldn't bring your head
honcho over so it was a guy i think he
was a crop duster from alabama named
jake jacobson had been in this pilot the
one that flew the one and a half tons up
and
built it in
and he told me you can come to miami
tomorrow
and uh
testify before grand jury you come down
first class with mari or i'll take you
down in chains i said i'll come down
first class
so i went down and i went to see one of
the best lawyers schooled and his
partner had been been assassinated for
representing a snitch
so i went and talked to him i said man
i've got to say something what i'm going
to say i can't i'm not going to testify
he said well i don't represent snitches
and my face turned red i said not a
snitch
he said well that's what you're talking
about
he said let me tell you something you go
in that grand jury room
and if you don't tell them everything
and barry's told them something
different you're going to get life
no matter one thing that you don't tell
them
so i went to the courthouse i supposed
to meet barry and
to to do it so i was standing there and
they came up and that cavacade and
had barry in between them and cars in
front and back and they stopped down
there and it was hot and they was all
looking out with the machine guns
looking out this way and that way and i
just reached up and hit the top of that
car bam
i said
they like to tow the inside of it i said
see how easy it would be
so i said fellas i'm having trouble
getting a lawyer
so uh well we and so he'd give me a name
of a lawyer or something so that night i
had uh dinner with mario in the festival
restaurant which was our favorite down
in carl gables and barry and debbie come
in
and uh
while we were finishing up so we had
dessert together and i hugged his neck i
said barry they're going to kill you
friend
no no no so i fled to brazil with mario
and children in july that killed him
that was on my birthday
january
1985 i guess six months later they
killed him yeah
and you saw that coming of course 100
percent and if you would have something
would happen to you
well of course it'd kill me but i mean i
wouldn't go into a halfway house every
night if i went and went to portugal or
something with my money and changed my
name up and all this stuff flew over in
a few years it was i would have been all
right but it was i didn't want to take
the chance because i didn't do it for
that i just i'm just not a snitch you
just you either are you're not in your
heart they killed him for snitching yeah
absolutely larry 100
the cartel yes
and you knew what your fate would be if
you did the same thing as him
well yes but
i i did i just
you could i could have taken the money
and went to russia somewhere and lived
behind the iron curtain they wouldn't
have found me
but i just didn't want to it just wasn't
me it's just not me
not to be telling somebody that i work
with made a deal with he's just a good
person how am i going to send him to
prison for life and me sit outside
i mean i don't want to go have you in a
terrible position but
i would hid anywhere somewhere instead
of doing that
[Music]
what's the toughest question your kids
asked you have they asked you a question
where you were startled or no
have they ever asked you a question
where you totally were like oh my god
that's the question i don't want to be
asked okay whenever
whenever i
went to brazil we got we changed the
name from reeves to odom that was my
great grandfather's name and the
children was and my little boy was just
five years old and was two or three
years with that and anyhow whenever we
had to change it back to reeves i had to
tell him
you know your name is really rhett
reeves
and he thought what and then it dawned
on him he remembered it
so that was just something uh
like a question you have to tell them
their real name what's your relationship
with your kids today all just wonderful
just
they're just full of love
and they're how old though
56 and 47 and 41. how old are you i'm uh
79 79 january 26 i'll be
uh january 43 43 1943
same age as your dad no he's one year
younger he's uh 30 year apart yeah my
dad's 42 yeah
very interesting well i mean listen i uh
uh first of all
uh what a story you've lived
uh we didn't even get into
90 of it on what we have for folks who
uh want to know more we're gonna put the
link below to your book smuggler
uh and uh
listen this is you know stuff that
we probably touched five ten percent of
the book
uh if you want to learn more about it
you can go order the book
um
i wish we had a couple more more hours
man because you're a great storyteller
you got a lot of uh interesting stories
that you're sharing with us and i think
there's more depth to it rather than
just many of these stories that are
entertaining i think there's depth to it
that have to do with character with how
to be a man
fatherhood relationships decision making
i think there's more to it there as well
but i'll give you the final thoughts the
audience has listened to you for a
couple hours
what final thoughts you have for them
oh boy
ask me questions i can do a whole lot
better than if you come up on the
thoughts i have i have an idea of prison
reform
that uh
particularly young people come in should
be sentenced to a uh to a trade
and i got a lot of flack over saying
that but uh they should be instead
you're going to give them 10 years or to
make a plumber
so instead of going to jail no you go to
jail and you go into a trade school in
jail
instead of you've got 10 years buddy but
soon as you were a class a plumber and
you got a job at 50 bucks an hour
you walk out that door and that would
take a he put a very interesting
why would they not implement something
like that i feel like just if you want
to have productive members absolutely
and people say well yeah do a crime go
get it get an education but those people
are just going to sit there and slam the
dominoes down for 10 years for nothing
and come out to do another crime it's
just sad
why wouldn't they do though i don't ask
a question i don't know i don't i don't
think they i don't think they don't on
them yet
and i'll just tell you that i i have
some good news about it i signed a
contract with range media partners to
make a series
congratulations you're working on it
yeah that's very cool very exciting i
mean i'm sure
uh these stories every story you're
telling me all i'm thinking about is a
movie i'm going to the scene so i want
to see it on the big picture myself
uh when these come out tell her did you
want to say something or you're unmuted
yourself okay
um roger really enjoyed this thank you
so much for coming to being a guest on
the podcast it's been a pleasure yeah so
we don't have nothing this week or we do
do we have podcasts on thursday podcast
thursday yeah thursday yo it's gonna be
a special one so hang tight we're gonna
have something special for you guys on
thursday thank you everybody we'll see
you there bye bye bye bye goodbye
you